- Please welcome, John Kanell!
(audience clapping and cheering)
- [John] Thank you for having me.
- Okay, I love your story.
You became a teacher.
You were a good teacher.
- [John] Thank you.
- But something inside of you
felt another path that you would foster
by cooking in your off-hours
and feeding your passion.
But what made it take
over into pole position?
- I mean, there's two
things happening here.
My mom is from Mexico
and she instilled a
love of education in me,
it's part of why I became a teacher.
But she also had a love of cooking
and exploring flavors
and just trying things
out and being adventurous,
and I grew up with her in the kitchen.
So even though I was a
math and science teacher
and I loved it,
I still had a passion for
cooking that I nurtured
and it really kept me going.
But when my husband, Brian, and I decided
we wanted to have a family.
- [Drew] And you guys live on a farm.
- We live on a farm now.
And like, we're both from LA.
Now we live on this farm in Connecticut.
And so we wanted to have kids
and I knew I wanted to
be home more with them.
So I took my love of
teaching and my love of food
and I created Preppy Kitchen
where I get to be home with the kids,
but I can also teach people
how to make delicious food
and have fun in the kitchen.
(audience clapping)
- And your husband,
Brian, is in the audience.
- Yes, yes, he is.
- What's it like to live with
someone who can really cook?
- Well, I'm incredibly well
fed, as you may imagine.
I like to consider myself
the chief tasting officer
of Preppy Kitchen.
So it's fun.
- I love that you call yourself
the chief tasting officer.
- I can't cook anything.
So I would starve to death without John.
- Okay, so your upcoming
book that I've been searching
high and low for is coming out in October
and it is my pick for Cookbook Club.
What can we expect?
- Well, we're all from LA, right?
- Yes.
- And when we moved to
Connecticut, I was like,
"I love this, this is amazing."
Like the summer was just magical
with like the plants breathing
and you can just feel it.
- You appreciate it.
- Yeah.
- So the seasons just affect
every part of your life.
- And that's a big part of your cookbook.
- And we arranged all the
recipes by the seasons,
because I have different
needs in the winter.
I wanna have cozy, just hearty,
delicious food like this.
- [Drew] And different stuff available.
- [John] Yeah.
(upbeat music)